I'm going to be sitting down with Tommy
Robinson this week to say,
Tommy,
he's a controversial figure,
would be putting it mildly.
You only have to glance it is twitter
mentions to see how some see him as a
modern day hero defending Western
society while others see him as a racist
thug.
Thankfully I don't get all my
information from twitter and neither
should you.
Tommy is the cofounder of the English
Defense League,
a movement that opposes Islam,
Islam and Sharia law in the UK.
He left the edl a few years ago after
connecting with my [inaudible] is
Quilliam Foundation because he felt the
edl had become too extreme.
Now,
Tommy is part of Paquita UK,
a subset of the bigger European paquita
movement,
which has the stated goal of preventing
the Islamification of our countries.
Basically,
Tommy thinks that the UK and now all of
Europe are in route to becoming Islamic
nations.
Time.
He reached out to me about two months
ago to see about being a guest on the
show before I said yes,
I actually had to do a bit of soul
searching.
As you guys know,
I'm beyond fed up with the regressive
left's labeling of everyone a bigot or a
racist,
but in Tommy's case,
are they actually right and if the
regressives are,
why should I even talk to someone with
racist views?
There's no doubt.
Tommy spends most of his time talking
about the dangers of Islam.
He certainly isn't hiding that,
but are his motives actually based in
bigotry?
It wasn't just those questions that had
me unsure whether to talk to him though
there was actually something else at
work and something that really exposes
the rot that the regressives are causing
in our society.
Part of me was actually afraid that if I
spoke to Tommy,
regardless of whether he really is a
bigot or not,
that I also would be labeled a bigot.
Let me repeat that.
I feared that just by having a
conversation with someone just by
hearing their views on this show as I do
every week,
that I would then get one of those awful
labels that people throw around thrown
on me.
After a couple of days of thinking about
it,
I realized that not only did I have to
do the interview with Tommy,
but my fear was the exact reason that I
had to do it.
The chilling effect that words like
bigoted and racist have are not just on
the person and who they are aimed,
but they're also used to stop other
people from talking to them.
The less we talk,
the more the authoritarians can move in
with easy answers.
Once I really wrapped myself around
that,
it was a no brainer like all my guests,
all at Tommy's ideas be heard and you
the audience will be the judge.
Ironically,
if the left had been more honest about
the dangers of Islam,
Islam all along,
I would feel less of a need to have
conversations like this,
but they refuse to.
So here we are.
If his ideas are good,
then let them spread.
If they aren't,
then let them be beat by better ideas.
As my former guests,
Douglas Murray said on Sam Harris'
podcast a few weeks ago,
it's too late to be willing to be
blackmailed by people who are
fundamentally insincere in their
insults.
That's exactly how I feel about labels
or pretty much any of the other nonsense
coming from people who would rather
stifled debate than have it.
This past weekend.
I rewatched one of my all time favorite
movies,
v for Vendetta and powerful speech to
London.
He says,
and where once you had the freedom to
object to think and speak as you saw
fit,
you now have sensors and systems of
surveillance coercing you're conformity
and soliciting your submission.
How did this happen?
Who's to blame?
Well,
certainly there are those more
responsible than others and they will be
held accountable,
but again,
truth be told,
if you're looking for the guilty,
you need only look in the mirror.
I think it's getting high time that we
all look in the mirror and decide what
we believe.
My guest this week is an author,
activist,
and former leader of the English defense
league is also no stranger to
controversy.
Tommy Robinson,
welcome to the show.
Thank you.
All right man,
so I want to start with this,
which is what I lead the show off with,
which is that I struggled with the
decision to even have you on the show
because I see what people say about you
and half of it is this guy is going to
save the Western world and then half of
it is he's a bigot.
He's a racist and plenty other stuff,
uh,
in line with that.
So first off,
do you get that often?
Do you get that people are sometimes
afraid to talk to you?
Um,
yes.
And there's a reason for that.
You will be targeted as high as anyone
else that speaks to me.
Oh Great.
By a campaign,
you will trust me.
You will.
I've just been asked last night it was
released on ongoing to be addressing
this,
the Hindu leadership of the UK.
I've been invited to an event to discuss
multiculturalism.
They've been targeted,
they're getting attacked now.
I expect that when I turn up,
if they're not forced or pressurized
into canceling,
which is what's happened with university
after university,
after university with schools,
anyone that asked me to speak,
even tv shows in the UK,
there's a conservative effort to silence
what I'm saying and to attack anyone
that gives me a platform to say it.
Yeah.
Well,
as I mentioned that the top,
that was really what my deciding factor
was to talk to you because I'm so sick
of everyone being labeled bigoted and
racist and all that.
That if I'm afraid to talk to you then
that that is almost a bigger problem
than bigotry and racism,
so that's why we have to do this,
I think.
Yeah.
You're,
you're in a minority that I so thank
you.
All right.
Well,
most people put their reputations or
their careers or what things are that
before free speech in the UK.
Yeah.
Well,
somehow I still have this belief that if
I talk about free speech that it'll
actually be good for my career.
We shall,
but why?
Why don't we start with this?
Let's just start with the most obvious
piece of meat.
Are you bigoted against Muslims?
Go to separate Muslims.
Whenever I,
whenever I speak,
I try to set up separate Muslims from
Islam.
I have an opinion on Islam in the same
way Islam has an opinion on me.
Islam is bigoted towards Muslims.
I'm not every Muslim,
of course,
every,
every Muslim is not bigoted.
Um,
if you,
if you've read my book that some of the
best meet people I've met in my life
growing up on Muslims,
I don't have a problem with Muslim,
but I do have a problem with the way
Islam is influencing my country.
I have a problem with the hatred that is
incited from it.
And um,
and we're fearful of what the future
holds.
Right?
So just to be clear,
and this is what I've spent a lot of the
time on the show talking about.
You're making a distinction between
Islam,
meaning the doctrine,
the set of ideas that are in books,
a between that and between the people
that may or may not be using these
ideas.
And as you said,
you've met plenty of Muslim people that
you liked a lot and you're making that
distinction.
I'll make that distinction in a similar
way to the fact that,
look,
if I was a critic of Scientology,
I would not be getting called a racist.
I would not be getting called any of the
things that I am just because it happens
that the majority of Muslims are not
white on,
beaten down and attacked with this
racist stick.
Which is ridiculous because Islam is an
idea.
It's an idea that should be criticize
and it's my God given right to criticize
it.
I don't incite hate against any
individual Muslims.
I've never ever there.
I let the English Defense League for
over six years.
Um,
I've never been done for any racism,
any extremism,
any insightful speeches.
In fact,
if people at the height of leading the
English Defense League when there was,
um,
when our soldier leaving,
he was beheaded in the streets of London
are very next demonstration.
I started my speech off by saying that
there are 600 Muslims who served in the
British armed forces that if you attack
a Muslim woman or you get spare Muslim
woman,
you're.
You're an absolute coward and I tried to
get the distinction between some things
are morally just and I think my campaign
is morally just and righteous and other
things,
a cowardly attack in houses of worship,
whether they be Christian or Muslim is
cowardly.
So from.
I've done that from day one.
In fact,
as far as the organization goes,
we've been a moderate voice in this in
this,
but we can put completely attacked as
extremists or hateful and insight and
hate.
Literally just this week I've gone where
we're having a demonstration in the city
of Birmingham,
which is Britain's second biggest city,
has it,
has a large Muslim population that has a
lot of problems there.
And I met a Muslim counselor and this is
the.
This is where the problem comes in.
And I said to him,
if an organization is completely
peaceful and there's no violence,
there's no alcohol.
Do they have a right to come to this
city?
And criticized as well,
and he said no,
and that's where we're at.
And I said,
why not?
He said,
because criticizing Islam insights.
Hey,
I said,
telling the truth can't incite hey,
and,
and that's where we've been beaten down
so much because so many.
And He,
he's a counselor for the Labor Party,
which is a mainstream political party.
So many people are against free speech
when it comes to Islam.
Yeah.
Well as my audience knows,
I mean this is really where the left has
failed.
And from everything that I'm hearing
from my friends in the UK and across
most of Europe,
sadly most of western Europe,
the left is failing everywhere.
Uh,
and the more that the voices of Liberals
are silenced,
the more that the far right is going to
be strengthened.
A,
you're probably somewhat of an example
of that.
So before we get into all the specifics
and everything that's going on today,
can you just tell me a little bit of
your history growing up when you became
politically active?
That kind of stuff.
So I grew up in a town called Luton.
Um,
so one of the most multicultural towns
in Europe when I was born in 1982,
there was one mosque.
Now there's an excess of 30.
We have approximately 50,000
Muslims.
We've had just last week for Muslims
from my hometown.
One which went,
went to my school,
had been charged with terrorism,
another young,
another Muslim who was a white convert.
Just again this,
this week has been charged with insight
and support for Isis.
My hometown was the launch pad for the
seven seven attack on London.
London's underground,
the fertilizer bomb plot.
Um,
the stock counting bomber.
Some of you may remember the stock
bomber.
He was radicalized in my hometown.
He lived two doors away from my army.
So Amazon Redeem Omar,
Omar Bakri Abu Hamza with the hook,
their head office and their
organizations base was in my town.
So I,
what's going on in their town?
What's going on in that sound is,
um,
we've had,
it's been the epicenter and the,
and the home of radical Islam.
And there'd been allowed with
unchallenged by councils or government
or police for 30 years to plan,
orchestrate,
and radicalize an entire community.
And we've filled in my hometown after
September the 11th in America when I
come out to my shops the next week,
we had magnificent noname posters
everywhere.
We had posters glorifying the 19 suicide
bombers.
Um,
the in the local college.
They celebrate it every year after that,
outside in our town center,
there was a celebration parade for the
Muslims who,
who,
who murdered on September 11th.
That's where I live.
So I've grown up from a very young age
and I have,
I have many of these,
what we call liberals in the UK,
they're not really liberals,
but or those on the left who condemn me,
they shout at me that they.
And they know nothing about the life
I've lived.
I think,
oh,
to the life I've lived that have not
seen what we've seen.
They don't live with the effects.
And when we talk about multiculturalism
in the UK,
we have our political leaders.
David Cameron has come out and said,
multiculturalism has failed.
Angela Merkel said years ago,
What they're actually saying,
what they're actually saying.
This Islams failed because in my
hometown and my group of friends,
the majority of them come from immigrant
backgrounds,
whether it be Saint Lucian,
Italian,
Bulgarian,
Jamaican,
Indian,
and everyone gets on fine.
And that,
and my town has been divided,
not through,
not through racial lines ever.
We don't have the racial problem.
I don't know if you believe you may have
in the US,
but we don't have a racial problem that
we have a religious tensions and the
religious line drawn through the
communities.
Right.
So when you saw this growing up,
uh,
you know,
you're not,
you're not that old,
right?
You're in your mid thirties.
When did your sort of awakening a
appear?
When did you say,
okay,
this is something that I'd have to talk
about and attach myself to?
So my,
my,
my awakening was,
um,
the Beslan school massacre 2000 and
2004,
I believe it was.
What it was was that I'd watch this
group,
this group,
how measure dean,
I'd watch them grow and and when I say
watch them,
one of the man who's convicted this
week,
who was an ex member of their
organization,
a white ginger convert would ebe room
Hansen,
his name is Roger.
Really?
I watched him convert.
I'd watched him become radical.
I'd seen some of my own friends who had
converted in prison and changed yet,
so I'd seeing it or seeing this group
and then I watched an interview after
the Beslan massacre where this group was
saying in my hometown that if it
happened to an English school,
it would be justified.
And I also knew that that group openly
converting and recruiting in my town
center where my family go.
Where were y'all go?
They were openly recruiting on the
streets every single Saturday to send
people to fight for the Taliban against
our armed forces.
And that was it for me.
That was 2004.
I organized my first demonstration.
I was aged 21 years old and I organize a
demonstration called bandaloop and
Taliban,
so it's hard to believe that.
So they're actually recruiting in a town
in England for the Taliban.
We know that a lot of Isis fighters are
coming from England.
They're coming from all of western
Europe basically going through Turkey
right into Syria.
What does law enforcement do about that?
It sounds like not much,
right?
I do nothing.
So what I did when I organize this
demonstration,
I actually made leaflets over 10 years
ago now and in those leaflets,
what we're going back 12 years,
so this was before people had heard of
homegrown terrorism in the UK before
people have heard of these organizations
and in the leaflets I made a point that
our daughters and our sisters are being
groomed,
which we now know as an epidemic called
grooming,
which is where groups of Muslim men
would get young girls and their gang
raped them and it's become an epidemic
across the UK,
but it's been going on for 30 years.
No one's ever spoke about it now.
Twelve years ago I made a leaflet which
went on the front page and one national
news of my local newspaper saying whites
and blacks are being religiously target.
Our women are being pimped and sexually
abused and prostituted by Muslim gangs.
I named the Muslim gangs.
I named the extremist organizations.
Um,
and I stood in the town center and read,
read this leaflet out wherever I said
that we demand that the police act with
demand that the council's act,
um,
there was no action after that.
In fact,
all that happened was I was targeted.
I was targeted by Muslim gangs.
Can some of the blame here be blamed on
something related to,
to British society that maybe we don't
have here in America,
America for all our faults and we have
plenty of racial problems and all kinds
of stuff.
We've done the melting pot pretty well.
Everyone is come here no matter where
they're from.
And pretty much mixed in bringing their
traditions and then,
and then becoming American.
It sounds like from the emails I'm
getting from Denmark and Sweden and all
this,
that something has happened in Europe,
but I guess specifically in the UK where
for whatever reason,
the Muslim population just hasn't
integrated the way that other immigrant
populations have been.
Some of that be on the fault of the UK
and not just the Muslim population.
Yes it can.
Yes.
It can be on the,
with multiculturalists who encouraged
all these people to come here,
told them that their culture was equal
to us,
told them that they can go back into
their own communities.
They can live as they did in Afghanistan
and Iraq and Pakistan.
Um,
and as soon as anyone like ourselves try
to scratch beneath the surface to say,
well,
let's see where we differ culturally.
Let's see where our opinions differ.
Then we've been screened down as racist.
And the reality is we need to
understand,
and you say it's worked relatively well
in,
in America.
You have nowhere near the percent of
Muslims in comparison to Europe and it
and it will not work well in America.
And that's the,
that's the bone.
And you need to realize is that you need
to learn from what's happening over here
because you're going to face the same
problems.
If you're ever uneducated Somalians
coming in uncontrollable numbers,
you will face exactly the same problems
I've.
I've grown up with a loop.
If you allow,
if you allow Saudi Arabia,
you allow guitar,
you allow around,
you allow them footholds in your country
with Salafist or what hobbies mosques.
You allow them to build schools and
teach these children hatred.
You will in the next generation.
The experience in the height I
experienced growing up.
So what do you think a town like yours
where it.
This has been growing for a long time as
you're saying what should be done at
this point?
I mean these people are citizens of the
UK.
So what should be done to fight these
ideas?
Not the people,
but to fight these ideas that are
spreading.
What,
what,
what shouldn't be done is my local
counsel spend 188,000
pounds of tax payers money given,
given to the Salafist mosque.
I'm not a master.
Causes us huge problem that that's a mos
that went off set,
went in into it.
They found books in the children's
school library for how to handsome fee.
Um,
we shouldn't be funding them.
We also should not be allowed in Saudi
Arabia or Qatar to fund these addresses
are popping up left,
right,
and center.
We should be tough on,
on,
on so many issues.
We,
we,
it's knowing where to start really.
And I think towns that haven't had the
problems at Luton have had,
should be looking to our town looking at
the infiltration.
What we've seen is the way the Muslims
control themselves and the way they
vote.
Then our local council no longer care
about us.
They don't care because we don't keep
them in power.
The Labor party are kept in power every
year in Luton by 30 to $50,000
remotes.
So we become irrelevant and that's spoke
bank politics and we don't vote based on
someone's ethnicity or we don't vote on
base somewhere.
Someone's religion,
but the Muslim community do.
That's all they vote.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
even as I'm talking to you,
I have this feeling because I'm a
liberal,
I have this feeling of,
you know,
is he exaggerating this like,
is this,
how big is this problem?
You know,
I follow you on twitter,
you tweet videos all day long,
have,
you know,
women being attacked either in the UK or
in Germany or wherever,
and sometimes I have trouble sort of
figuring out how much of this is
actually happening all over the place.
How big are the problem is versus is it
just this micro problem?
Uh,
and I guess I guess your answer would
be,
well,
if it's a micro problem in my town,
but it's,
it's spreading into this big macro
thing.
The problem is bigger than anyone can
comprehend.
And that's why the political leaders,
that's why police forces,
that's why it's now a fact in the UK
that police,
social workers councils conspired to
hide these tracks for,
for decades.
Can go into that a little bit because
there's been a couple,
a couple controversies about that.
Yeah.
So,
so there,
there's been a rover and rapport before
this Robin,
Rapport Ppp.
We used to,
people used to say I was lying or
inciting hate,
and I choose to say it because it
happened to my cousin,
the similar sorts of crimes and we knew
what the police reaction was then,
so there was a robin report and in depth
report into one little small town in the
north of England in that small town,
there's a population of male Muslims
that are aged,
aged between 18 to 40.
There's about 3000 now in that town.
They identified 1,400
young English girl who had been beaten,
prostituted,
and right in unbelievable numbers.
Some of the goals right?
30 Times in one night and when they've
done this big report,
what they've found in the report
actually was the council knew full well.
The head of the police knew the Muslim
community knew everyone knew this was
happening,
but the reason why they'd done nothing
was through the fear of being branded as
racists.
That's how powerful political
correctness is.
Now two,
are there circumstances in this report
where the.
When the police turned up and there was
a young girl who was 11 years old and
she's been in a derelict house by five
Muslim men now when the police turned
up,
they arrested the girl for being drunk
and disorderly.
I let you've got to read the report that
you've got to read the report and also
there's another circumstance where the
go the go.
Two of the girls who were taken and
these girls were missing for days at 12
years old,
13 years old,
14 years old.
They're going to miss him for dates.
Two of the girls were taken,
so the dads went to get the girls back.
The goals were inside the house.
The dads have gone to the Muslim's house
to get them back.
When the police turned up,
the police arrested the English girls,
dads,
they left the goat,
and so these sort of things,
which one of your view is that they
sound unbelievable.
They sound unbelievable actually.
They're in a government report.
This is going on across our whole entire
country.
This isn't just going on in our country
is going on in Holland.
It's gone on across Europe.
Look at,
look at what's happening in Sweden and
this is comes from a mindset and a
culture and an ideology that teaches
them that Muslim Muslim,
not just more women are inferior but not
non Muslim women like ours,
that dirt.
Not that that's not all Muslims because
some Muslims I've grown up with would be
as disgusted as we are,
but what?
There is a problem if you look at the
statistics for these not paedophilia
because the majority of pedophiles in
the UK are white,
which you'd expect from a 90 percent
white country.
This is a new,
a new epidemic that men share young
children with their brothers,
their cousins,
their work colleagues that the level,
the viewing of it within the community
or within the group is not viewed in a
similar way to how we would if it.
If a member of our community.
He said,
I've got this young 12 year old girl
that you'd fill them in,
but this is something very,
very different and it's new to the
country and what we're seeing now.
We've seen it with Cologne again,
with on New Year's Eve is now been
putting people's faces more than ever
and we feel.
I feel I've got two young daughters.
I've got two young doors.
We have to.
I was just speaking before about a
professor who,
who Angela Merkel's given a speech this
week in a university and the professor
has stood up and he's heckled her and he
said,
I'm scared.
I have children.
What,
what,
what?
What future are you bringing to our
children?
This is an experiment you know nothing
about and that's the reality of it and
it's not an experiment.
We know nothing about.
We know what's going to happen.
We know what's going to happen from case
studies.
Luton town is a blueprint for the rest
of the UK.
It's a blueprint for the rest of Europe.
It's a blueprint for America.
What's happening here?
It's happening everywhere.
Yeah.
It's incredibly chilling,
listening to you,
and again,
that's why.
That's why I wanted to talk to you and
try to get a sense of the size of this
whole thing.
I saw a video this week.
Did you see this?
A 16 year old girl posted a video from
Germany talking about how she went to
her local supermarket and she saw these
guys staring her and they were migraines
and they were.
She really be was a afraid for her life.
She posted a 20 minute video on
facebook,
which she clearly delineated.
She said,
I have nothing against Muslim people.
I have friends that are Muslim.
All of that stuff.
She said,
these people,
these specific people that are coming
now,
there's something different and from
what I understand,
the video was taken down and she was at
least temporarily suspended from
facebook so that that really shows you
how perverse the political correctness
has got.
If now facebook is in on it too.
Oh,
facebook's completely.
Everyone keeps getting suspended for
posting videos or pictures of the
reality and the truth.
That young girl,
my.
That angers me so much more than I can
even express when I watched that and I
could well up in my eyes and thinking,
she's not free to walk to our shops in
Germany in 2016.
Why is she not free?
Because hordes of hoards of Muslim men
are coming in from a completely
different culture,
a completely different view on women are
completely different that we have to
understand their mindset and what gets
me is that I'm all for helping refugees.
These are not refugees.
Sixty percent,
60 percent this week.
The EU commissioner has come out and
said they're economic migrants.
Sixty percent.
Angela Merkel was open those borders to
one and a half million last year.
There is going to be a flood in the next
coming years of tens of millions of
Muslims come into come into Europe,
come into our continent where that go
and her feeling is just going to be
natural to everybody.
Everybody's going to be feeling and we
shouldn't feel fearful.
When our in our own homes and towns and
we do all we had,
all I ever hear about is Islamophobia.
All we ever hear about is that Muslim
women are scared.
I'm not being funny,
but no one's raped Muslim women.
No one is gang rape in Muslim women.
No young Muslim goals were attacked on
New Year's Eve.
No Muslim has had their heads hate cut
off in the street.
No,
this is not happening to Muslims and,
and that's,
and that's where when we look at the
target,
and I had a meeting this week with lead
it,
with a leading of a seek,
a safe organization.
You should talk to him.
He,
he can give you a real in depth of
what's going on from a sales
perspective.
He deals with hundreds and hundreds of
young children who have been taken from
their families by Muslim gangs.
Um,
and in the most recent one when I went
with a radio presenter and the radio
presenter said,
where's got nothing to do with religion?
And he said,
well actually everything they're saying
to the girls while rape is about
religion is a religion or race or I can
go through the court cases where there
was a smiley,
Smiley and rape gang down in Bristol in
the UK.
And he actually said it was his
religious duty to do this.
This is really.
And these are not what we're saying is
what they're saying.
They're saying,
you white trash,
you whitefield will gut you like a pig.
All of these comments are being made to
these young English girls and all
everyone wants to get around.
The fact is,
oh,
everyone's or everyone does it.
No,
not 90 percent.
The 90 percent of the convictions,
the street gang grooming,
our Muslim men have a population of four
percent.
Well,
you know,
I really am starting to see this as
almost a disease of the mind of people
on the left because even if even if
everything you were saying was being
magnified by 20 percent,
50 percent,
let's say you're,
you're totally doubling the,
the severity of all of this.
It's still a problem.
And every time I hear my friends on the
left talk about it,
they'll immediately say,
well,
you know,
Christianity,
there were the crusades or the Catholic
Church has covered up molesting children
for hundreds of years.
All these things.
No one's denying those things,
right?
And some of those things are still
happening right now,
but that doesn't mean that what you're
talking about isn't a problem.
So my question to you is,
when in the UK did the left go off the
deep end,
you say,
what will I keep trying to say?
And I've tried to save for six years now
this is not a left wing or right wing
issue because people will automatically
pigeonhole myself as right wing or no,
actually that's a lie.
I'm pigeon holed as far.
Right,
right.
Or Am I ugly?
Um,
whereas the majority of people who have
supported my organization over the
years,
many of them would have been left wing
Labor votes.
Um,
so
to be clear,
the reason they'd be left wing is
because they're for women's rights,
right.
And they're probably for gay rights and,
and they're generally for minorities.
So they should fit on the left.
But yeah,
that'd been pushed and forced to the
right.
And that's because the left in the UK
politically rely and have basically the
Labour party in the UK,
they're,
they're loyal vote bank used to be
working class people like myself.
Yeah.
In,
in England we have a very classist
system.
I don't think you've experienced the
same in America,
but we have a very classist system.
We have the bottom and the top and you
have what is fundamentally,
usually conservative people were very
wealthy and working class people are
usually quite poor or not,
or not quite poor,
but Paul and proud anyway,
but what we.
What we then see is that as,
as as working class people started doing
better,
they would then aspire to be
conservative because they get more
money.
Yeah.
Right.
So then it seems that the Labor Party,
you just completely give up on this,
on this section of the community,
and they went straight for which Tony
Blair is.
That government has have admitted,
bring in in loyal votes,
which were immigrants which have now
become Muslims.
There's one speech where you can.
Anyone can watch it.
It's his name.
So He'd met Malik and he's a.
He was a Labor MP for Jews,
Brie.
And in his speech,
he clearly tells us,
Satan,
in 2001 we had one Muslim MP in 2004,
we had free freedom is an MP in 2008 we
had eight Ms Dot mmps.
And in between saying each thing he
says,
inshallah,
inshallah and up.
And he says,
we've been 15 years in this country.
The majority of Mps will be Muslim and
then or the crowd,
which is a thousand or cheer and clap.
And then he says in,
within 30 years the prime minister of
this nation will share our faith.
Now again,
or say,
don't listen to what I'm saying.
There's plenty of Muslims.
And when he says this as a
representative for the Labor Party,
this is the problem.
When you mix religion with politics,
which is now happening,
just it goes like this.
Now actually,
um,
we have the Labor Party,
which is the leading left wing
organization.
When they have their meetings in Muslim,
predominantly cities,
they segregate the odd audiences.
They segregate the audience is men and
women in law,
in with Sharia.
This is a party that's supposed to stand
up for women that's supposed to stand up
for gay people's rights.
And that's why I'm,
I have our contempt and disgust with
what the,
what the Labor Party and the left have
now become.
But that doesn't mean all left wing
people because Islam is something that
should concern and especially the
literal interpretations of it shouldn't
concern everybody on the left and every
liberal should be screaming from the
rooftops or what's happening.
I know,
believe me,
I wish they were so just as long as
we're going on the political side of
this.
You were part of the British National
Party for a while,
I think about 10 years ago.
And you left because you thought they
were going too far,
right?
You thought they were becoming racist
and that caused you to leave.
Correct.
So what happened was that,
that was when,
when I spoke about the pendulum school
massacre,
which when I was 21,
I started looking online to find who's
talking about these things.
And there was only one group talking
about and they were called the British
national Pi.
Um,
I joined the British National Party on a
12 month.
They had a meeting,
so I went along to the meeting and I
joined in that meeting in my hometown.
They then set up a second meeting where
we were going to bring.
Our friends were not turned up with my
friends to the second meeting.
They said he can't come in,
he can't come in.
It was the black lines with these
English lads.
Yeah,
they're my best friends.
So they said they can't come in.
So I said,
what do you mean they can't come in?
And they saw non non white people can't
join the British National Party.
Now I was 21 years old,
never involved in politics,
never an interest in policy.
So I didn't realize then that the leader
of this organization is named Nick
Griffin.
I didn't realize he was a holocaust
denier or didn't realize that I didn't
realize that he used to be leader of the
National Front and RC organization.
And so from that,
which there was a leaked membership
list,
which is how people know I as a member,
but I didn't rejoin the next three
years.
That was my flirtation with the British
National Party was done.
Or then in 2009,
about five years later,
I sat the English Defense League.
I set that up based on my own
principles,
which,
where anyone can join.
We actually went onto have a Sikh
division I lesbian and gay division,
a Jewish division.
Um,
and anyone that's affected by these
problems because I've,
I've grown up in a town where I don't
care about other cultures.
I don't care about.
I don't care if you're gay,
I don't care if you're straight.
None of that bothers me.
My problem is with this radical,
this radical ideology,
which is going to cause us all serious
problem.
So it's up.
But like did leave the English Defense
League as well?
Yes.
I left in 2013.
I left because I found that a lot more
time.
The majority of my time actually it was
not spent trying to tackle the issues it
was spent trying to keep backward inbred
far right Nazis out of the movement.
Right.
So that's a really interesting point and
I think it's sort of illuminates your
story a lot,
so to be clear you left one party
because they didn't want black people
basically in their party.
And then when you started the edl where
you had plenty of people from all walks
of life joining you,
you ended up leaving that too because it
went too far.
Right?
So when people paint you as this ultra
right nationalist,
whether they agree with all the other
stuff you're saying or not,
that just.
It just isn't true from any estimation
that I can see
anyone.
Anyone can spend five minutes on Google,
you can go to these ultra right wing
Nazi nationalist organizations and see
what they think of me.
I get just as many death threats from
them.
I'm known as the real far away.
See what happens is I get called fire,
right?
The real far right in the UK.
I'm a Zionist.
Do that.
That's why from the real Pharma,
of course,
of course.
Yeah,
So real quick though on when you left,
the edl that was facilitated by
Quilliam,
which is marginalizes organization
that's trying to foster coexistence.
I've had my jacket on.
I,
I hugely admire him.
Can you just real quick explain how he
helped facilitate you getting out?
I was leaving.
I was leaving the organization anyway,
so I was leaving.
I'd made the decision I was leaving.
I then met,
imagine the was and I'd known of their
organization and some of the work that
done anyway.
I'm,
if I'm honest,
it benefit me and it benefited him at
that time and I'm,
that's just me being completely honest.
I,
then I then spent some time with
Quilliam who are seen as reformist
Muslims.
What,
what I realized it was the many of them
are,
if they're honest,
are apostates.
Um,
they don't follow the teachings of
Islam,
which is why they're saying able to say
what they do,
but then because of that
softening the blow,
so to speak,
they're not coming out right and saying
we don't believe in this.
They're saying we're trying to reform it
just because that's a little more
palatable,
sort of.
Yeah,
but then their target that I actually
hate it more than me.
They're actually hated more than me by
Muslims and then the more time I spent.
Look,
I met Majeed.
I'm a Sama,
has a summer seminar,
still site is one of the most sincere
and decent men I've met in my life,
but they.
They're not being entirely honest with
the public about where we're at.
I've done some training in there and I
was taught that when we talk about Islam
missed so that the acceptable word now
is that we're against Islam is we're
against Islamism,
which if so then what they said is
Islamist ideology and they wrote a graph
and through this chart and it was
punishment for adultery,
a punishment for homosexuality.
Oh,
the older backward ideas that come out
of it.
But,
and they said that 90 percent of mosques
in the UK are propagating this.
Not Ninety percent of the Muslims in the
mosque,
but 90 percent of the mosque because
who's funding and controlling them and
the hierarchy and the teachers.
And the mom's 90 percent of whom can't
speak English,
Iva,
they're 90 percent of the Masa propagate
and Islamist ideology and they.
They had Islamist ideology under folks
Islam and then they had true Islam,
which I said 10 percent work,
but obviously I have a huge problem with
this because if 90 percent of
propagating this in the UK,
that's true Islam,
I get what you're trying to do and I
wish you.
I wish you every success in trying to
change this,
but we've had 1400 years of history that
shows it hasn't changed.
You're fighting a battle now where,
and I asked him when the last time I saw
a Sama,
Sandra,
I said,
how many people have you converted to
your liberal form of Islam this week?
Because while you've been doing that,
radical extremists in prisons across
this country and Taoist tools across
this country are probably converted
thousands.
Yeah,
and I want to get to the prison part and
a little bit because you've had some
completely insane experiences in prison,
but just to wrap this part up,
the interesting piece here is that
although you're not working with my
jihad now you guys in your own way,
you're both apostates to your community.
He's considered,
you know,
I see all the horrible things that
people call him,
porch monkey and terrible things coming
out of the Muslim community saying about
him and coming from white people on the
left,
which they'd be considered racist if
they said it about about a black person
of course,
but in a way you both are now sort of
outcasts and that kind of brings you
together.
Which to me,
that's where the real conversation is.
Whether you work with him or kill him
ever again.
That's,
that's the lane that this has to go
down.
The conversation is,
but this isn't a time for conversation.
It's like it's.
If we could rely on Muslims to solve
this problem.
If I'm at the opinion now,
we can't.
Unfortunately.
I think I spent two years float in there
with different groups and talking to
every moderate Muslim I'm introduced to
just tomorrow night in the UK.
There's a BBC radio four program and I
went last week because we're going and I
traveled round me in Muslim leaders
again and when I met this account or
extremism,
counter terrorism hailed as the most
moderate of Muslims you can get.
When I sat down with him,
I said,
will you please condemn punishment for
apostasy in the Islamic states?
Whether that be in Saudi Arabia just
anywhere in the world,
please condemn it,
wouldn't do it.
I said,
you can't even condemn that.
Someone has the freedom to think you
can't even do that.
He goes,
well,
we're not there.
I said it.
That's not hard.
It's not difficult if you want people to
be punished for thinking a different way
or you don't,
and this is another Muslim that's hailed
as the most moderate and to be honest,
if I can't say I've met one of other
match in the West other than some of the
Muslims in Quilliam,
other than that,
older and older Muslims I've met and
I've.
I've pushed them on questions.
I found that once I scratched onto
beneath the surface,
actually they hold some quite a point of
views.
They do and if it was time for,
if Muslims could solve this problem,
then the combined military force around
in 50 to 100,000
isis soldiers or Isis Millan's is up to
$5,000,000
combined military force and they've done
nothing and they're not going to.
So we,
we have,
we have to do things now.
We have to enforce laws.
We have to push agendas that are going
to make sure that we're secure and to
make sure that we are not just secure
but stable in the future and we can't
rely on Muslims to do.
Okay,
so you bring up some of what's going on
with the prison system in the UK.
You've been to prison a couple times.
Actually,
I think about two weeks ago.
You might've been in prison for a day or
something.
Is that right?
I'm almost arrested.
I've been arrested and charged again.
Yes.
Yeah.
So I don't want to get too much into the
things that you've been arrested for.
Some of them sound like extremely jumped
a trumped up charges.
This is a lot of what your book is
about,
but can you talk a little bit about what
your experience was like in prison and
how powerful the ideas of Islamism are
actually spreading in the prison system?
Sorry,
from the first time I went to custody in
2004,
2005 things have moved forward very
quickly within the prison system,
so to say.
Then the next time that I went back into
prison was um,
2010 for actually illegally enter enter
in America,
but that was,
um,
2010.
And what I've witnessed each time I've
been in custody would terrify anyone.
And I honestly say that if you could see
the maximum security prisons that were
the most dangerous prisoners and most
dangerous men in the UK are being used
as ics training camps,
training camps,
the white labs,
the black glass,
everyone is converting,
everyone has a big huge bed.
It is the biggest gang in the system.
And it's something that the authorities
have not got grip off.
They can't control the mom,
God bless them.
Some of them are,
are trying,
um,
but they're seen as student.
He has to.
So the moms,
people are not taking their Shahada and
converting to Islam in the mosque on
Friday.
They're,
they're doing on the wing,
on the prisoners wings.
They run their own mosques.
So this is going to sound sort of
amateurish because I've never been to
prison.
But when you've been there,
what,
like how is it that these ideas spread?
Why is it that the prison system is
allowing,
and I know this,
this is in the United States,
do with,
there's all kinds of crazy religious
stuff that goes on in prisons and drug
deals and all,
you know,
it's all nuts.
But what is going on that that they are
even allowing these ideas,
bread,
they call it,
stop them.
I can't stop.
It's say Islam forms of Providence.
I probably heard you mess with one
Muslim.
You mess with every Muslim.
So in some instances Islam is being used
within the prison system,
used for power control and money is
something that anyone can attach
themselves to.
And and that's what's happened.
But it's also been orchestrated and
organized to you see in in British
prisons where if a Muslim gets another
non-muslims convert outside,
sources are sending them in money.
Yeah.
To.
And also if you know the ideology of
Islam,
it's the pathway to heaven.
For them,
it's the pathway to heaven is to spread
Islam,
to spread dour and to convert prisoners.
But what you're seeing then is some of
the most dangerous and extreme people in
the UK are converting to Islam.
And it also gives,
when I say it's powerful,
we look in the UK,
we've lost our identity through
political correctness and for years and
years of being beaten down.
English people have lost their
community.
We don't have the community feeling that
the Muslim community have and when
you've lost your identity and your tour
time and time again,
or you're told Time and time again that
your identity and your culture and your
history is not good,
and then and then comes along this,
this powerful,
powerful community that will stick
together and we and you'll never be on
your own and it gives them everything
they had been searching for.
You have to remember a lot of people who
are in the prison system have been wrong
their whole life from a very young age.
They.
They've done a lot of wrong as well,
but there's a reason many of them and
chose that path.
They've started with nothing.
They've had nothing.
They've got nothing.
Islam gives them a course.
It gives them something to fight for.
It gives them something to concentrate
on it and it all.
I've seen a lot in my life,
but what I saw happening in the prison
system,
I don't know how we're gonna deal with
it.
I think steps we can take.
If you look at the statistics in French
prisons that have a population of,
I believe seven percent Muslim,
70 percent of the prisoners on Muslim in
the UK.
I spoke to prison officers who said that
in one week they had 60 conversions
because a Muslim gang had come into the
prison and just started beating an
attack and everybody to convert and then
before you know it,
everyone just converse for the,
for the easy time because if you're in
trouble when you want protection,
you convert.
So when you were in jail,
speaking of being beaten,
you were beaten basically to a pulp,
right?
I mean all your teeth knocked out and
really some horrible stuff,
but you'd never converted.
So how did you even,
or I guess just talk about the violence
that you were subjected to first.
So I was in the UK prison system.
They have laws and rules that they have
to follow.
They have a duty of care for every
prisoner.
Now what they did when against every
single one.
So I'm under no doubt.
In fact,
if I,
if I taught when I was taken to woodhill
here was a maximum security prison in
the UK,
the houses,
some of the country's most feared and
dangerous terrorists.
I was in prison for a financial
irregularity on a form for that,
for that offense.
You go to an open prison where you go
home.
I was taken to a maximum security
category,
a prison.
I was Po,
Po,
po in my cell,
and that very first day when my daughter
first I opened it,
it was an ex world marine commando who's
a British,
the British military,
and he said,
when they come to get you from cell,
do not leave this cell,
and I went,
what?
He goes,
you're life depends on it.
Don't leave this cell,
and then 10 minutes late he's come with
two other prison officers and said,
come on.
You're going to be with.
Obviously I'll say that I'm not going
anywhere.
I'm not.
I'm not leaving this cell because I
didn't leave the so I didn't get
arrested,
so I'll get further charge,
but I'm arrested and then.
And then I go to see Miss Lisa.
The next day and I have a meeting with
my solicitor about what's happening when
they take me back after the meeting and
they opened up a waiting room and as
soon as I look in the waiting room,
I see the big huge beard of a white,
a white convert on putting into the room
of about eight people in it and I'm
violently attacked and the door's
locked.
The door was locked by the prison
officers,
the doors locked and I'm left to be bit
by Libyan and then not just that,
but I was arrested again for fine.
They said,
but that's just one experience in the
prison system.
To be honest.
I'm lucky and I believe that people were
pulling strings in order to have me
killed.
Now I think even that they are
scratching their heads to how I walked
out and that's just one experience
that's happened.
Time and time.
Mind you said,
I spent a day the other week in custody.
Again,
this was.
This was quite recent,
just probably six months ago.
I was coming to the end of my license
period with the authorities where they
have you on a control order.
I wasn't allowed to contact people who
are in the organization are used to,
used to.
And this was for a mortgage,
a so called mortgage for it.
Anyone who reads,
reads,
reads the story of what happened.
We'll see what it was all about.
But I was um,
I was taken from the last eight days so
it lost its or put back in prison.
I was taken to a prison called
Peterborough where I said at the stars,
so there's got days left.
I dice,
I'm going to get killed.
Yeah,
just put me in,
put me in isolation.
I don't care if you don't open the door
for eight days.
The idea is let me go home.
I'll come out with myself and I've
talked to prison officer again.
I said,
look,
we know what's going to happen here.
And they've said,
oh,
we'll have a word.
And then I prisoners come up to me what
an English prison.
And he,
he put his hand over his mouth.
He said,
you're going to get done with Baltimore
now in prison,
in prison.
They put boiling water with sugar and it
takes you,
it will take your face off.
So I'm looking,
I've got two minutes to think.
I said who's going to do it?
And he said,
the lag behind the door has put the
money up because he'd paid money to have
me her.
Now the lag behind the standing next to
the door was doing 28 years in prison
for a murder where they can't,
a man's nose,
eyes,
ears off,
making odium.
Now there was four of them in for that
murder.
I'm in eight days.
I am known as someone who,
who has,
uh,
I've had,
Al Shabaab have named me to be killed.
I've had six government ultimate
mornings sign that there is
intelligence.
I'm going to be murdered by Muslims.
And here I am doing eight days house
with Muslim murderers.
Sorry.
And then,
um,
so my mind's going quick.
I already know that.
I've asked the principal far to
segregate me.
So there is no luck there.
I look across,
I know I do what I had to do and before
he has a chance to turn around with his
comp,
I strike him and then and then the
prison,
old older screws.
The prison officers come and jump in.
Now.
I went before the prison governor for
that offense where I explain myself.
I said,
look,
you put me in this position where I've
got.
I have to defend myself.
They decided to take no further action.
I was then I was released from prison or
they went on a holiday with my wife and
children.
I landed back at home at Luton airport
at midnight and the police were waiting
for me.
They arrested me in front of my kids and
they arrested me for the,
for attacking the Somalia and prisoner
who was going to do me a boy.
The more they then made a decision in
October last year to have no further
action,
so they said,
we're not taking any further action.
I then recently,
just two weeks ago,
I launched a Poquito UK,
which is a new organization to have
street demonstrations and two days later
they come and they come and rearrested
me for the offense that they'd already
dropped.
This is a lot of what your book is about
and it's sort of this endless cycle that
you've been part of.
Um,
and I know we could talk about the
prison stuff forever because you're just
scratching the surface of it,
but let's talk about Paquita a little
bit.
So I think you just got back from
Germany.
You were doing something with them in
Germany,
is that right?
Yeah,
I'll just come back last night.
So I went to Copenhagen First,
um,
where I bought British journalist with
us.
So we went to Copenhagen to sort of
launch Paquita in Denmark and to ask the
people to stand with us on the sixth of
February because on the sixth of
February we're planning demonstrations
in 14 countries.
Now this is the first time a coalition
like this has been formed and it's only
been made possible by the people,
by the commitment,
and the people have dressed and their
leadership have looked back mountain and
the other.
The other is interesting because for the
last year,
every single Monday for 52 weeks,
they have taken to the streets in their
tens of thousands of times.
The,
the,
the demonstration.
I just went through this Monday,
there was well over 10 to 15,000
people there in a completely peaceful
and civilized manner to express their,
their concern,
free passive resistance.
So what's happening?
So just to be clear,
when,
when this,
uh,
this mass attack happened in Cologne
just a couple of weeks ago,
at the beginning of the year,
uh,
it seemed like the police were not
there.
People did not know who to turn to.
A women were literally were being raped
and attacked and all of that stuff.
And then there were some demonstrations
a couple of days later,
I think in Colona and some other cities.
And suddenly there were a lot of police
to police the people that were there to
protest the violence that happened to
the women.
Something really backwards here.
Oh,
is there at that demonstration?
I.
I know exactly what it is.
When you,
when you get large disturbances of
Muslims,
the police do stairway.
They.
Because if they go in with their bands,
if they go in and try and please the
streets provoke a riot and that riot
will spread and they know that so that
we've seen that many times when we hang
up here,
I can send you a video after video,
which actually shows the police running
away in the UK.
Now they don't run away from us.
They knock your teeth out and knock your
head off before they run away.
When it comes to,
they're told to police the communities
differently.
Now on New Year's Eve,
the head of the police actually asked
his superiors.
He asked for an extra hundred police
officers.
He was refused.
And then what we saw was these massive
attacks and these mass rapes of of
German women.
And you're right there no one to turn
to.
And only traveled out there for the next
demonstration.
And Lo and behold,
you've got thousands of police officers.
You've got water cannons and I'm German
people were attacked with water cannons
by the police.
So is the situation in Germany
particularly precarious even though you
mostly focused in the UK because that's
where you're from.
I've heard a lot of people say that in
Germany because of the guilt related to
the Holocaust that they,
they feel as a nation a certain amount
of guilt.
So when,
when these migrants and uh,
all these people want to come there,
they feel an extra need,
uh,
to help them.
And because of that,
that's why Merkel let in the whatever it
is,
I think it's one point 2 million people
and that even when they do violent acts
as a society,
they're more condoning of it because
they know that their ancestors have done
some pretty horrible stuff.
Well,
this generation of Germans seem to be
living with and suffering from guilt
from Hitler.
The next generation of Germans will
suffer and live with guilt from.
And so that's what I need to wake up to.
This generation.
Have nothing to feel guilty about.
They have a beautiful country,
a beautiful culture,
the envy of the world,
and they're beautiful people,
so civilized and decent people and they
have nothing to feel good.
We also,
so what?
What this is is underestimation of,
of the culture and ideology.
They're allowing it.
That's what it is like if everyone's all
make him humanity responses,
we must help these people but not help
them.
If it involves the destruction of your
culture and your and your country,
not help them at the cost or the expense
of young German goes that and I'm all
for helping refugees.
I just don't think they should be helped
in Europe.
I think they should be helped in the
Middle East.
I think that we should be leading the
way in funding and military support to
make sure that there are buffer zones,
but I don't think they're important and
to be honest,
by important one point 2 million this,
is she making any impact on the
suffering of of refugees across the
Middle East because there's tens of
millions.
Whatever option is there bring bring the
whole of Syria into Europe.
It solves nothing is nothing and what
she's actually done by doing this,
this,
she's opened up the flood gates and we
will now see absolute stampedes of of
tens of millions over the next five
years.
Well,
I've also read a bunch on how it's not
just about the violence,
but also just the actual system,
the systems that are in place.
The social systems.
You know,
I was reading something this morning
about how all of these people that are
coming from Syria,
they,
all,
a huge percent of them have really bad
teeth.
Their teeth are really bad now they're
going to get free dental coverage and
it's going to cost something.
I sleep with something like a billion
euros or something,
but they're not going to pay for it,
so the average German taxpayer is going
to have,
have to pay for it and then that right
there,
when their taxes go up,
then naturally they're going to be more
resentful of these people.
So it's,
it's hitting people in the,
at the economic level and at the violent
level.
It just seems like a terrible mix.
A society.
It's going to hit them everywhere.
I believe 80 percent of them can't read
or write.
I believe the many of the real refugees
that have come from Syria are going to
be suffering from PTSD,
post traumatic stress,
stress disorder.
Um,
they're going to need counseling.
They're going to need help.
There's so many problems that will come
from this and we say one point 2
million,
but they were allowed to bring their
families after for years.
Right?
And they're loud and they're allowed
their EU passports.
So that one point two will become six or
eight.
It doesn't have the infrastructure.
I'm simply.
But what Angela Merkel was fully aware
of is that they won't stay in Germany.
They're going to come to countries like
mine.
She knows.
And in fact,
just last week,
the German government have come out and
said,
we've lost 600,000
refugee.
We've lost them asylum seekers.
We have lost them.
They're not where they said they
weren't.
They've got now 600,000.
How many of them are rapists?
How many Isis fighters?
How many are criminals?
We have no idea.
No idea at all.
So let me ask you this,
because a lot of this,
you know,
at some level you hear the people
throwing around the term Trojan horse a
lot and a lot of it sort of sounds like
a conspiracy that there has been this
organized effort to just influx all
these people.
And I think I've seen even in some of
the videos that you've tweeted when you
see just like hundreds or thousands of
migrants crossing,
it does seem like it's 80 or 90 percent
men.
Men that are 20 or 30 and you don't see
a lot of women.
You see occasionally you'll see some
women in some children,
but it does seem like a lot of men.
But to go that route,
it sounds like a conspiracy theory to go
and say,
oh,
this is.
There's an intentional plan to flood
Europe with these people to ultimately
take over.
But I suspect by the 15 minutes we've
spent together,
you don't think it's much of a
conspiracy.
That can be no other reason.
Anyone with any common sense and
intelligence or brain can kind of look
at what's happening and know it's not
going to be good for Europe where anyone
can look up what's happening to Angela
Merkel made comments such as,
um,
immigrants are more prone to violence
and extremism than the non immigrant.
She,
she said that years ago she's also made
comments saying that multiculturalism
has failed.
They've already failed in integrate
millions of Muslims.
So why is she bringing in millions more?
What reason?
If anyone can else can give a reason.
And how are these millions?
Well,
what do you think?
What do you think actually,
what do you think is going on in her
head then?
If everything you've said here is true?
Angola,
Merkel,
she was just time.
Woman of the year,
right?
I mean this is a,
this is a bright lady,
right?
So what about
under Angela Merkel has no children that
she cares not for the future of our
country or our people.
That's truthfully what I feel.
I don't think she cares about,
about the future of her people.
And at the same time,
you have this,
this,
as you said,
people holding up on a pedestal at
first,
at first,
wherever it was for,
I can't say it was through ill intention
because I think they know that everyone
knows full well what this is going to do
to Europe and we know full well what's
going to happen and what you're seeing
is actually the only countries in Europe
that are freely speaking honestly,
are the countries that don't have a I a
high percentage of Muslims.
It's Poland,
it's hungry,
it's Czech Republic,
Slovakia.
They are political leaders are coming
out and saying what needs to be said now
if you look at the UK is former
political leaders.
If you look at Sir William Gladstone,
he held the Koran above his head.
He in parliament and he said that Islam,
there's this Koran is a violent and a
curse book and we will never be have
peace on this earth.
So long as we have this book.
Winston Churchill said,
the individual Muslims will show amazing
characteristics,
but the backwardness of Islam has the
power to bring Europe back to the dark
ages.
Now there are two world leaders,
we have statues that the whole world
loved,
and if they were around today,
they will be called bigots and
extremists and that simply for telling
the truth,
my prime minister,
prime minister,
says that Islam is a religion of peace
and the facts speak very different to
that.
And at the moment the problem we have is
that by telling the truth,
which even if people don't like the
truth,
we have to be honest.
I
so think when people say Islam is a
religion of peace or Christianity's
originally piece or Judaism is a
religion of peace,
it's a moot point.
Uh,
religion is because of religion is only
a set of ideas.
All the religion is,
is what it's adherence do,
right?
It's a religion of peace that that means
nothing.
That an idea is what people do with it.
So I find those statements like that
just don't add anything to the
conversation.
No.
And we hear them after every terrorist
attack,
every single terrorist.
That's what,
that's what we,
that's what we talked.
And in fact,
it's not what we're talking about.
I'll give it to other circumstances.
Now as a parent,
as that,
I was studying the biography of Mohammed
and I'm sat at home and I'm preparing
for a debate and my daughter who is
eight years old,
she walked past me and said,
[inaudible],
I don't,
I never taught my children.
They think my kids never heard of the
English Defense League.
Yeah.
I lived two very separate lives and I,
I want to protect them for as long as
possible from understanding these
politics.
Daughter walked past and said,
Mohammed,
peace be upon him.
And I looked and I said,
what did you just say and why did you
just say that?
And she said,
well,
it's taught at school.
You have to say peace be upon him.
Said peace be upon him.
And then,
and that was one incident.
Then another incident about a mosque.
And then when I took my children to look
at another school,
um,
one of the things that,
one of the things they had to do was put
the different religious buildings with
the different religious words.
Yeah.
The only one my daughter could do the
religions of the world was his mom.
Because what's happening now in the
national curriculum in the UK is that
Islam is the favorite religion.
Islam is what's being pushed and
propagates all of our youth and children
and they're brainwashing either mind if
they want to talk about Mohammed,
tell the truth,
tell us about the man or he was not a
man of peace.
Some of the things he'd done with some
such immoral thing.
No,
he killed a lot of people.
That's a fact.
It's a fact,
but they're not teaching that.
They're teaching this.
This is great man.
This great man,
Mohammed,
that we must all respect and say,
peace be upon him.
That's what they're teaching.
Eight year old English go children.
So then by the time that next generation
come out at the schools,
there been brainwashed into this mindset
and as soon as your parents even.
I've seen it across the country,
parents who have not wanted their
children to be taught these things and
then branded as racist as well.
I moved for the truth being taught to my
kids,
but then I haven't even spoke to my
children if I haven't spoke to our
children about Islam.
Are All one school talking to him about
it?
Well,
that's one of the strange things and I
think we see this a little bit in
America where they'll say,
well,
we need to learn more about Islam
because of this.
And to me it's like we should not be
learning more about Islam.
We should not be learning more about
Christianity.
Judaism or mormonism or jainism or any
of them.
What we should be learning about our
secular values.
We should be learning about the things
that tie us together.
Not all the little differences that are
just gonna split us.
I,
I'm completely in agreement.
It's just a fundamental problem.
I always say that I believe in secular
schools.
I think we should have secular schools,
but they're not.
I don't believe we should also,
um,
I don't believe that shouldn't pose,
pose a problem for,
for safe schools or schools or Christian
schools because because they're not
causing us the problems that we face.
These huge problems that we face
currently are caused by Islam.
They're inspired by Islam.
And if they want to sit in schools and
talk about Mohammed,
they need to tell them that he,
he,
he raped a child,
he married a child,
he committed murder,
that they didn't need to tell the truth
and they're not.
So then we have this complete ward down
educational system that is lying to the
next generation of youth in the UK.
Yeah.
Um,
all right.
Well we have to wrap up and I feel like
there's so much more we could talk about
and hopefully with the way I prefaced
this whole episode,
people will learn about you and they can
make the decisions,
you know,
whether they think you're a racist or
whether they think you're preaching the
truth or somewhere in between.
Uh,
but just to wrap up,
um,
give me something that you think,
give me some hope here.
Give me some hope.
I mean,
you're working with piggy now.
It doesn't sound like a hate
organization to me.
So give me some hope for an ability to
turn some of this around.
And first and coexistence
Europe is you can end up hugely the
people of Europe.
You have just seen a declaration called
the fortress Europe,
which is called the product declaration,
which for in different countries now
have assigned to you on the sixth of
February for the first time there's
going to be demonstrations in England,
in Holland and Denmark in Germany,
and the Czech Republic in Poland all
simultaneously at the same time.
This is the star of a friendship and
partnership has been not just Europe,
actually,
Australia also marching with us.
We hope that by the next time we have
America,
we have Canada,
we have India,
we have the world because this is a
worldwide problem we have to face.
And um,
yeah,
there is hope and they'll always be hope
because to be honest,
I know whole heartedly that our love for
freedom and democracy will always
outweigh their,
their,
their hatred for Sharia.
Yeah.
Alright,
well listen,
it was really interesting talking to you
and I'm sure we'll,
we'll keep talking,
but I was going to send people to Amazon
to buy your book,
but Amazon took your book off,
didn't they?
They took it off and put it back up
three times.
Right?
So I'm not sure if it's up right now,
but they can definitely get your book at
Tommy Robinson Dot Co dot UK,
and they can get the kindle version at
least in America yet on Amazon.
Yeah.
Uh,
all right.
Well it was a pleasure talking to you
and uh,
you know,
it's difficult stuff,
but that's why we have to have these
conversations.
So I thank you for coming on.